terminations found that this was within
the jurisdiction of the Director of
National Intelligence that it was an
urgent matter and it met the statutory
requirements that it dealt with a
serious or flagrant abuse violation of
law or other misconduct or
you
and they shall provide it to the
Congress and they shall instruct through
the inspector general the whistleblower
how the whistleblower can come directly
to Congress in the absence of that
whistleblower law there is no lawful
mechanism for intelligence community
employer detailee or contractor to raise
a complaint about serious misconduct
right the whole point of the
whistleblower statute is not only to
encourage those to report problems
abuses violations of laws but also to
have a legal mechanism to do so and not
to disclose classified information
because there's no other remedy that
whole purpose is being frustrated here
because the Director of National
Intelligence has made the unprecedented
decision not to share the complaint with
Congress we were informed of this fact
after the seven day period in which the
director has to review it and submitted
to Congress had expired no complaint was
provided and the Inspector General felt
it necessary to inform the Congress that
that complaint was being withheld in the
absence of the actions and I want to
thank the Inspector General in the
absence of his actions and coming to our
committee we might not have even known
there was a whistleblower complaint
alleging a urgent concern we will be
releasing the inspector general's
letters but I want to read one sentence
from them mr. Atkinson wrote I set forth
the reasons for my concluding that the
subject matter involved in the
complainants disclosure not only falls
within the DA's jurisdiction but relates
to one of the most significant and
important of the dn eyes
responsibilities to the American people
this is what's being withheld from
Congress right now we do know that the
Department of Justice has been involved
in the decision to withhold that
information from Congress we do not know
because we cannot get an answer to the
question about whether the White House
is also involved
preventing this information from coming
to Congress we do not have the complaint
we do not know whether the press reports
are accurate or inaccurate about the
contents of that complaint but what I do
know is this if in a matter within the
jurisdiction of the Director of National
Intelligence you have an employee of
that community or a contractor a detail
they who follows the law and makes a
complaint and it is possible for the
subject of that complaint to essentially
quash the complaint or keep it from
Congress then this system is badly
broken now I don't think this is a
problem of the law I think the law is
written very clearly I think the law is
just fine the problem lies elsewhere and
we're determined to do everything we can
to determine what this urgent concern is
to make sure that the national security
is protected and to make sure that this
whistleblower is protected because the
impact of this opinion which the
Department of Justice has been unwilling
to share with us the impact of this
opinion is that if the Department of
Justice decides that an employee of the
intelligence community who comes forward
follows the law follows the process is
nonetheless outside the process they're
not protected which only means that this
whistleblower is not protected it means
no whistleblowers protected that is the
danger of the DOJ x' misinterpretation
of the law so that is where we are right
now next week we will have an open
hearing with the Director of National
Intelligence where he can explain to the
country why he believes this urgent
concern should not be shared with the
Congress but that's where we are and
I'll be happy to respond to
all I do know is this I don't know
whether the White House's is directly
involved because we can't get an answer
that question but we do know that they
are making some claim that a privilege
may apply well that narrows the category
who may be intervening here we also know
that there are other institutions
involved that are preventing us from
getting the complaint and whether this
is pressure brought by the White House
whether this is the Director of National
Intelligence feeling that he is
straitjacketed by this opinion of the
Department of Justice whether the
Department of Justice is coordinating
its activities without the White House
or the subject of the complaint we don't
know but given the Inspector General
said this is urgent it can't wait which
is a profound concern that we have over
what we have seen over the last year
which is a concerted strategy to run out
the clock on any information getting to
Congress here where it's urgent that is
simply not an option well there is no
privilege that covers whether the White
House is involved in trying to stifle a
whistleblower complaint and I should say
that even if you could make a colorable
claim of privilege over the subject
matter of the complaint given that it
involves something that the IG has
already found to be serious and credible
and evidence of wrong
of one kind or another there is no
privilege that covers that there is no
privilege to conceal that there is no
privilege to be corrupt and so that
needs to be provided to Congress we
can't get an answer because the
Department of Justice and the Director
of National Intelligence will not
authorize the IG to tell us and the
Inspector General is doing his very best
to be very careful that he follow the
law and in some respects the Inspector
General is in the same position of the
whistleblower which is if the Inspector
General steps one foot outside of what
he's authorized to do then he is not
protected and so this shows how someone
is trying to manipulate the system to
keep information about an urgent matter
from the Congress well we know a few
things we know that this is a manner as
I just read the language of the
inspector general this is the inspector
general is a non partisan neutral
official here and we have no reason to
question his judgment his judgment is
this is not only within the BN i's
jurisdiction this is squarely within
what the American people expect of a
Director of National Intelligence so who
is in a position to countermand that who
is in a position to influence an Acting
Director of National Intelligence who
has not been on the job very long to do
something completely unprecedented which
is to go outside of his own agency and
seek an opinion about whether he has to
provide this to Congress there are a
limited number of options that also
implicate privilege and so
the shorter answers we don't know but
there's certainly a lot of indications
is someone at a higher pay grade than
the Director of National Intelligence I
believe that there is an effort to
prevent this information getting to
Congress and if the assertion is
accurate that the Department of Justice
has made and the DNI is affirmed that
this involves a potentially privileged
communication then at one level or
another it likely involves either the
President or people around him well we
will hear more we will learn more next
Thursday when the Director of National
Intelligence testifies and we are
exploring with the House General Council
what our options are I would imagine if
it comes down that we have to go to
court to get this that we will have a
very good case to seek a temporary
restraining order or a mandamus or some
urgent form of relief because the
Inspector General has said this cannot
wait so this is not a situation where we
can afford to go through weeks or months
of litigation in this court of that
court there's an urgency here that I
think the courts will recognize I hope
that's not necessary and I hope that the
Director of National Intelligence will
reconsider because it's my understanding
that by law he can provide this to us
and indeed by law he's required to
provide this to us but we will look at
whatever remedies we have including when
the Director of National Intelligence
comes to the Congress for authorization
to reprogram funds for one purpose or
another we will look to whether he is
abiding by the law in making a decision
about those requests so we will use
whatever leverage we can but at the end
of the day we are
and to validate the whistleblower
process to make sure that people can
expose wrongdoing and because because
what's at stake here goes well beyond
this complaint and this president to
whether any oversight is possible any
whistleblowers protected and we're
determined to validate that authority of
the Congress
[Music]